The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Let's get started.
So today we're going to
talk about capabilities,
continue our discussion of how
to do privilege separation.
And remember last week we
talked about how Unix provides
some mechanisms for
applications to use
if they want to privilege
separate the application's
internal structure.
And today we're going to talk
about capabilities, which
is a very different way of
thinking about privileges
that an application might have.
And this is why we have actually
these two somewhat distinct
readings for today, one of which
is this confused deputy problem
and how to make your privileges
much more explicit when you're
writing software so that
you don't accidentally
use the wrong privileges.
And then the second
paper is about the system
called Capsicum, which is all
about sandboxing and running
some piece of code
with fewer privileges
so that it, very much
like [INAUDIBLE],
if it's compromised, the
damage isn't that great.
Now it turns out
that the authors
of both of these
readings really think
capabilities are the answer,
because they let you manipulate
privileges in a rather different
way from how Unix, let's say,
thinks about privileges.
So to get started, maybe let's
look at this confused deputy
problem and try
to understand what
is this problem that Norman
Hardy ran into and was
so perplexed by.
So the paper is
written-- well, it
was written quite
a while ago, and it
uses syntax for file names
that's a bit surprising.
But we can try to at least
transcribe his problem
into more familiar syntax
with Unix-style path
names, et cetera.
So as far as I can
tell, what is going
on in their system is that they
had a Fortran compiler, which
sort of dates their
design at some level, too.
But their Fortran compiler
lived in /sysx/fort,
and they wanted to change
this Fortran compiler,
so they would keep statistics
about what was compiled,
what parts of a compiler
were particularly expensive
presumably, et cetera.
So he wanted to make sure this
Fortran compiler would somehow
end up writing to
this file /sysx/stat,
that it would record information
about various invocations
of the compiler.
And the way they did this is,
in their operating system, they
had something kind
of like the setuid
that we talked about in Unix.
Except there, they called
it the home files license.
And what it means is that
if you ran /sysx/fort,
and this program had this
so-called home files license,
then this process that you just
ran would have extra privileges
on being able to write
everything in /sysx.
So it would have these extra
privileges on everything
in /sysx/, basically, star.
It could access all
those files in addition
to anything that it could
access because the user ran it,
for example.
So the particular
problem they ran into
is that some clever user
was able to do this.
So they would run
the Fortran compiler,
and the Fortran compiler
would take arguments very much
like GCC takes arguments.
And they would compile
something like foo.f.
Here is my Fortran source code.
And they'd say, well, put that
output -o into /sysx/stat.
Or more damagingly
in their case,
there was another file in
/sysx that was the billing file
for all the customers
on the system.
So you could similarly ask the
Fortran compiler to compile
the source file and put the
output into some special file
in /sysx.
And in their case,
this actually worked.
Even though the user
themselves didn't
have access to write to
this file or directory,
because the compiler had
this extra privilege--
this home files
license, in their case--
it was able to
override these files
despite that not being really
the developer's intention.
This make sense?
This is the rough
problem they ran into?
So who do they blame?
What do they think went wrong?
Or how would you
design it differently
to avoid running
into such problems?
So the thing they sort
of think about here,
or they talk about
in this write up,
is that they believe this
Fortran compiler should
be very careful when it's
using its privileges.
Because, at some level,
the Fortran compiler
has two types of privileges.
It has one stemming from the
fact the user invoked it,
so the user should be
able to access the source
file, like foo.f.
And if it was some
other user, maybe
it wouldn't be able to
access the user source code.
And in other sorts of privileges
is from those home files
license thing that allows us to
write to these special files.
And internally, in the
source code of the compiler,
when they open a
file, the compiler
should have been very explicit
about which of these privileges
it wants to exercise
when opening a file
or performing some
privileged operation.
But their compiler was
not written in this way.
It was just called
open, read, write,
like any other program would do.
And it would implicitly use
all the privileges that it has,
which combines-- well,
in their system design,
it was sort of the union
of the user privileges
and these home files
license privileges.
That make sense?
So these guys were really
interested in fixing
this problem.
And they were sort of calling
this compiler this confused
deputy, because it
needs to disambiguate
these multiple
privileges that it has
and carefully use them
in the right instance.
So I guess one thing
we could try to look at
is how would we design
such a compiler in Unix?
So in their system, they had
this whole files license thing.
Other mechanisms, then they
introduced capabilities.
We'll talk about them shortly.
But could we solve
this in a Unix system?
Suppose you had to write
this Fortran compiler in Unix
and write to a special file
and avoid this confused
deputy problem.
What would you do?
Any ideas?
I guess you could just
declare this a bad plan.
Like don't keep statistics.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sure.
That could be, right?
Well, yeah.
So you could not
support flags like -o.
On the other hand,
you might want
to allow specifying which
source code you want
to compile so that maybe
you could read the billing
file or read the
statistics file, which
maybe should be secret.
Or maybe the source
code has-- maybe you
can support a the
source code on standard,
but it has include
statements, so
it needs to include other
pieces of source code.
So that's a little tricky.
AUDIENCE: You could split up
the application [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So another potentially good
design is to split it up,
right?
And realize that this
fort compiler really
doesn't need all these two
privileges at the same time.
So maybe we should have our Unix
world /bin/fortcc or something,
the compiler, and then this guy
is just a regular program with
no extra privileges.
And then we'll also maybe
have a /bin/fortlog,
which is going to be a special
program with some extra
privileges and it'll log some
statistics about what's going
on in the compiler.
And fortcc is going
to invoke this guy.
So how do we give this
guy extra privileges?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, maybe if you
use something like setuid
or something, like fortlog,
then presumably any other user
could also log arbitrary
data through it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is not so great.
Because on fortlog,
presumably the only way
to give extra
privileges in Unix is
to in fact make it owned by, I
don't know, maybe the fort UID,
and that's also setuid.
So every time you run it, it
switches to this Fortran UID.
And maybe there's some
special stats file.
But then in fact anyone can
invoke this fortlog thingy.
Which is maybe not great.
Now anyone can write
to the stats file.
But maybe this example is not
the biggest security concern
about someone corrupting
your statistics.
But suppose this
was a billing file.
Then maybe the same problems
would be slightly more acute.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But you can always
make your [INAUDIBLE] stats
you want, right?
Instead of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So in
some sense, yeah.
If you're willing to
live with arbitrary
stuff in your statistics
or logging file,
then maybe that's true.
AUDIENCE: Even if
you [INAUDIBLE],
you can already make your C
code have whatever statistics
that you'd want to be recorded.
PROFESSOR: You could.
Yeah.
So it might be
that in this case,
it doesn't really matter that
you can log arbitrary stuff.
So that's true.
Yeah.
So if you cared about who can
invoke this fortlog thing,
could you really do
something about it
in Unix, or not so much?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
It would make both
of them setuid.
Now the fortcc would
read that source files.
It would switch back to the
saved UID, just the user UID.
Remote fortlog in
a setuid, which has
permissions to execute fortlog.
And that fortlog would
setuid again [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
So there is this rather
elaborate mechanism in Unix
that we skipped on last
Monday's lecture, that
actually allows an
application to switch
between multiple UIDs.
if it was setuid to some
user ID, then it could say,
well, now I want to
run with this user ID.
Now I want to run with
this other user ID.
And it could sort of carefully
alternate between these.
It's a little tricky
to do it right,
but it's probably doable.
So that's one potential design.
I guess another hack you
could maybe try to do
is make this fortlog
binary only executable
to a particular group and
make fortcc a setgid binary
to that group.
It's not great, because it
obliterates whatever group
list the user had initially.
But who knows?
Maybe that's better
than nothing.
Anyway, so it's a
fairly tricky problem
to solve in an entirely
satisfactory fashion
with these Unix mechanisms.
Although, maybe you should
rethink your problem
and not worry about
your statistics
file as much in the first place.
But how do we think about what's
going wrong in the design?
Well, there's two things we
could try to learn from this,
or basically, what went wrong.
And one interpretation that
one party wants us to take away
is this notion that he
calls ambient authority.
So what is ambient authority?
Can anyone figure
out what they meant?
They've never
exactly defined this.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It means you
have the authority given
to you by the environment.
So as if [INAUDIBLE]
user with no limitations.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you're making an
operation, and you can specify
what operation you want.
But the decision of whether that
operation is going to succeed
comes from some extra implicit
parameters in your process,
for example.
And in Unix, you can figure
out what this ambient authority
check might look like.
So if you make a system
call, then you probably
supplied some sort of a
name to a system call.
And inside of the
kernel, this gets
mapped to some
sort of an object.
And the object presumably has
some kind of an access control
list on it, like the permissions
on a file, et cetera.
So there are some
permissions that you
can get from the object.
And that should decide
whether an operation
is going to be
allowed on this name
of the application supplied.
This is sort of what the
application gets to see.
Inside of the
kernel, there's also
the current user ID of the
process making the calls.
So this is the current prox UID.
And this thing goes
into the decision
of whether to allow a
particular operation or not.
So it's the current
process user ID
that's this ambient privilege.
Whatever operation you're
going to try to do,
the kernel will actually
try, in some sense,
as hard as possible to allow
it by using your current UID,
and your current GID and
whatever other extra privileges
you might have.
And as long as there's some set
of privileges that allow you
to do it, it'll let you do it.
Which is maybe
not the best thing
to do if you aren't fully aware
of what all these problems are.
Maybe you don't want
to use all of them
to open a particular file or
make some other operation.
Does this make sense, roughly
what ambient privilege is?
In the case of an
operating system,
it basically ends up being
the fact that a process has
some sort of a user ID.
Are there non-OS examples
of ambient privilege
you guys can think of?
Like when you're making
an operation, something
about the identity of
the caller, the terms of
whether they'll succeed or not.
Like one example is
probably firewalls, as well.
So this is just an OS example.
And in privilege, another is
the firewalls on the network.
Because any operation
you do from a machine
inside of a firewall is
going to be allowed because,
well, you just have
that IP address,
or you're on that
side of a network.
And if you're outside, the same
operation will be disallowed.
So it's also a solar problem.
Say you visit some website,
and the website includes a link
to some different
server, well, maybe you
don't want to use the
privileges that you have
or the inside of your
network to access that link.
Because maybe it'll access
your internal printer
and exploit it in some way.
And really, the guy that
provided you the link
shouldn't have
been able to reach
the printer in the first
place, because they
were on the outside.
Or a firewall that your browser,
maybe by visiting uplink,
will be tricked into doing this.
It's sort of a moral
equivalent of this confused
problem on the network models.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] permission
are directly affected also.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because it's
essentially DAC, potentially,
in the Capsicum.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is pretty much
what the Capsicum guys
think of as discretionary
access control.
And the fact that it's
discretionary, well,
this is not quite what
discretionary access control
means.
But what discretionary
access control means
is that the user, or
the owner of an object,
can decide what security policy
will look like to an object.
Which seems very natural in a
Unix setting. it's my files,
I can decide what I want.
I can give them to you, or I
can keep them private, great.
So almost all DAC
systems do look
like this, because they want to
have some sort of permissions
that a user could modify
to control the security
policy for their files.
The flip side is
mandatory access control.
We'll talk about it in a little
while, but at some level,
they have this very
philosophically different view
of the world.
They think, well,
you're the user.
But someone else will
set the security policy
for how you use this computer.
And this sort of came out of the
military in the '70s or '80s,
when they really wanted to have
classified computer systems
where, well, you're
working on some stuff
and it's marked secret.
I'm working on some stuff
that's marked top secret.
So my stuff just
can't go to you.
It's not up to me whether
to set the permissions
on a file, et cetera.
It's just not allowed
by some guy in charge.
So mandatory access
control is really
trying to enforce these
different kinds of policies
in the first place,
where there's
the user and the
application developer.
And then there's some guy
separate from the user
and the developer
that sets the policy.
And, as you can sort of guess,
it doesn't always work out.
Well, we'll talk
about it in a bit.
But that's what discretionary
versus mandatory
means at this control.
All right.
So there's many other examples
that you could imagine where
we have ambient authority.
And it's not inherently bad,
law but it's just something
that you have to be
very careful about.
If you have a system
with ambient authority,
you should probably
be very careful
if you're performing
privileged operations.
You should make sure
that you're really
using the right authority
and not accidentally being
tricked very much like this
Fortran compiler 20 years ago.
25 now.
All right.
So this is one interpretation
of what goes wrong.
And it's not
necessarily the only way
to think about what
goes wrong, right?
Another possibility
is that, well,
wouldn't it be nice if it
was easy for an application
to tell whether it should
access a file on behalf
of some principle?
So maybe another problem
is that the access control
checks are complicated.
So in some sense, when the
Fortran compiler is running,
and it's opening a file
on behalf of a user,
it basically needs to
replicate the same exact logic
we see drawn out here, except
that the Fortran compiler needs
to plug-in something else here.
Instead of using its current
privileges, and all of them,
it should just
replicate this check
and try to make it with a
different set of privileges.
So in Unix, this
turns out to be fairly
tricky to do, because
there's many places
where these security
checks happen.
if you have symbolic links,
then the symbolic link
gets looked up, and
that path name also
gets evaluated with someone's
privileges, et cetera.
But it might be
that, in some system,
you could simplify
this access control
check, where you could do it
yourself in an application.
Does that seem like a
reasonable plan to you guys?
Would you go with that?
Any dangers of
replicating these checks?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, if you do the
checks in the application,
you could just
not do the checks.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you could easily
miss the checks.
That's absolutely right.
So in some sense, what the
Fortran compiler did here,
well, they didn't even bother
trying to do the checks,
now that they screwed them up.
Another possibility, in
addition to missing the checks,
is maybe the kernel
will change over time,
and it will have slightly
different checks.
It will introduce some
extra security measure,
and the application
will be left behind.
And it will implement
old style checks.
And probably not a great plan.
So recall, one good
idea in security
is to have economy
of mechanisms.
So there's only a small number
of places that are enforcing
your security policies.
You probably don't
want to replicate
the same functionality in
applications in the kernel,
et cetera.
You really want to boil
it down to one place.
That roughly makes sense?
OK.
So what is this
capability, I guess,
idea where thinking might
solve this authority problem?
Well, there's some formal
definition for the thing.
But really, you can get very
close by thinking of Unix file
descriptors as a capability.
So I guess the alternative
to this picture,
in capability world,
is that instead
of having the
application supply name,
and you look up an object,
you get a permission,
you decide whether
to allow it based
on some ambient
authority, instead,
the capability is the
picture looks very simple.
You have a capability, and
if you have a capability,
it points to an object.
And maybe the capability
has some small number
of restrictions of what
you can do with an object.
But basically, if you have
the capability to an object,
you can access the object.
It's actually very simple.
So there's no ambient
authority that
decides whether an
operation on a capability
is going to be allowed.
The only thing is that
maybe the capability has
a couple of extra bits, or
this mass that they described
in the paper, which
says, well, you
have a capability for this
file, as it's restricted
to read operations only.
Or it's restricted to write
or append operations only.
And then your security decisions
are all of a sudden very easy.
Because if you
have a capability,
you can do something.
If you don't, you can't.
Make sense?
So I guess one important
property of capability
is that they should
actually be unforgeable,
as the papers talk about.
So what does it mean
to be unforgeable,
or why do we want this
in this capability world?
Well, I guess this actually
may be almost too obvious here.
Well, if you can make
up any capability
you want-- I can make
up a capability for any
of your guys' files
and go access it.
So if I can make it
up, and I'll access it,
and there's nothing else in the
security design, that stops me
from accessing an object once
I can manufacture a capability.
So it's important that
these capabilities
can't be made up out of
thin air by the application
or by whatever's running.
How is this getting forced, if
we think of file descriptors
as capabilities?
So many of you guys
actually submitted this
as the big question
about Capsicum.
What do you think?
What prevents an application
from synthesizing a capability
in this file descriptor world?
Could you synthesize
a capability?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, it was
probably like a structure
and a construct
that says that they
have a capability for
certain file descriptors.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it's actually
fairly easy to see
what goes on once you
look at what exactly
is a file descriptor, right?
So a file descriptor
is basically
just some sort of an integer.
And this integer--
like in Unix, you
have file descriptor 0,
which refers to your input,
file descriptor 1 which
refers to your output.
Rockwell
But really, these are just
integers in user space.
And this is what the
application can presumably do,
and it can choose
any integer it wants.
But whenever you
try to do something
to a file descriptor, which
is one of these integers,
the kernel will always
interpret the integer
according to your current
process's file descriptor
table.
So for every PID-- let's
say, well, this is PID,
I don't know, 57.
So I'm process running.
It has an open file
table, and each integer
from supply from
user space, refers
to some entry in this table.
And of course, the kernel
should check that the integer
is in bounds in this stable.
It isn't negative.
It doesn't go past
the end of the table.
Otherwise, it will have
the usual buffer overflow
problems, et cetera.
But if you carefully
check that the integer is
in bounds in the
kernel implementation,
then the only possible
things that the application
can refer to by
a file descriptor
are entries in this table.
So presumably, the
kernel will somehow
make sure that you legitimately
guard a particular capability.
So when you, for example, open a
file outside of this capability
model in Unix, well, the kernel,
after the open call succeeds,
it's going to change that
file descriptor table
entry to point to a
particular open file,
like maybe open/etc/pwd.
And now, the entry at
this slot on the table
points to an open file.
Some of them might
actually be null.
Maybe you don't have an open
file with a particular index
in this table.
And as a result, what does it
mean to forge a capability?
The only thing you
can do in user space
is make up an integer.
And the only integers that
would make sense to make up
would be entries that point to
non-null entries in this table.
And those guys are exactly the
capabilities that you have.
So does that make sense why
it's difficult, in this file
descriptor world, to
actually forge capabilities
in the first place?
So it's kind of cool, right?
Like the only files that
you have opened are exactly
the things you can operate on.
And there's nothing else
that you can potentially
touch and effect.
Make sense?
Any questions?
All right.
OK.
So I guess, how
would capabilities
help solve the ambient
authority problem
that Norman Hardy is excited
about with his Fortran
compiler?
So what would be the file
descriptor moral equivalent
solution to this
sysx/fort thing?
Do they actually
solve the problem?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, they just use
the appropriate capabilities
whenever they're needed.
So when you have to access the
output file, in the statistics,
you use the capability
[INAUDIBLE] file.
But when you're accessing the
file you're about to read,
you don't use that capability.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I guess really what it
boils down to is that somehow
the Fortran compiler should just
already have a file descriptor
open for that /sysx/stat file.
So they don't really describe,
in their short paper,
about how we don't
get that capability.
But it basically means
you shouldn't really
pass file names around.
You shouldn't set
past file descriptors.
So you could actually come
up with a perhaps much more
elegant design for our Unix
replacement on the Fortran
compiler using capabilities.
So maybe the plan is we should
just have a Fortran compiler
front end that doesn't
have any extra privileges,
and it takes all these arguments
you give it, and converts
all the path names you supply to
it into open file descriptors.
So the alternative design
I am thinking of here
is that maybe we'd
have a program
fort1, which is the front end.
And it would take some
sort of a file, foo.f,
and all the other
arguments, -o, whatever.
And it doesn't actually
implement any of the compiler
logic, anything else.
All it looks for is path
names in its arguments,
and it's going to open
them and establish
file descriptors for them.
And the cool thing
is that, because it
has no extra privileges, if
the user can't have access
to some file name,
then it will fail.
Those are great.
And then once this front end
has opened all these file
descriptors, it can execute
some privileged extra component,
like the actual setuid
Fortran compiler.
So maybe then it'll run fort.
This guy's maybe setuid to
some special user ID that
has access to the stats file.
But it doesn't actually accept
any path names as input.
All it's going to do is
accept file descriptors.
And, in that case,
the file descriptor
is already prove that the
caller had access to open them.
Does the property make sense?
So it of course doesn't
solve every issue.
I'm just sort of sketching out
how capabilities might help.
But that's roughly the plan,
is that you should demonstrate
the fact that you have
access to a particular name
by just opening it and passing
a capability, instead of saying,
why didn't you try
to open this file
and maybe accidentally
use some extra privileges.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So does
this generalize
to having one process
per capability?
PROFESSOR: Does this generalize?
Well, of course you can have
as many processes as you want.
You can have multiple
processes per capability,
but I'm not sure--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm still not sure
what you mean by one property.
AUDIENCE: So we have [INAUDIBLE]
capabilities the user has.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: And then we
have the fort.s access
to this past file.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
So the way to think of it
is, you don't necessarily
need a separate process
for every capability.
Because here, the fort1
thing might open many files
and might pass many capabilities
to the privileged fort
component.
The problem here--
the reason that this
might seem like you
want a separate process
for every capability
is that we're
sort of dealing with this weird
interface between capabilities
and ambient privileges.
Because fort1 sort of does
have ambient privilege.
And what we're
doing is basically
we're converting this ambient
privilege into capabilities
in this fort1 process.
So if you have multiple
different kinds
of ambient privilege, or
multiple different privileges
that you want to carefully
use, then maybe what you want
is a separate process
holding that privilege.
And whenever you want to use a
particular set of privileges,
you'll ask the
corresponding process
to please perform a separation.
And if it succeeds, give
me back the capability.
So that's maybe one
way to think of this.
There's been actually some
operating system designs that
are entirely capability-based,
there are no ambient privileges
whatsoever.
And it's kind of cool.
Unfortunately, it's more of
sort of an interesting reading
experience.
Like oh, yeah, you can do it.
That's pretty cool.
But it's probably not
really practical to use
in a real system, unfortunately.
It turns out that you
really do want not so much
ambient privilege but being
able to name an object
and tell someone about an object
without conveying necessarily
the rights to that object.
So maybe I don't
know what privileges
you might have over some
shared document, but I do
want to tell you, hey, well,
there's a shared document.
If you can read it, read it.
If you write it,
great, write it.
But I don't want to
necessarily convey any rights.
I just want to tell you, hey,
there's this thing, go try it.
So it's a bit of a bummer
in a capability world
that it really forces
you to never talk
about objects without conveying
rights to that object.
So it's an important
idea to know about,
and to use it in some
parts of a system,
but probably not the
be all end all solution
to security, much like almost
anything else [INAUDIBLE]
about here.
Make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if the process
has capabilities given to it
by some other process,
and it happens
to already have the capability
to that object, that's greater.
Can it compare them to
make sure that they're
about the same object?
Or will it just use
the one that's greater?
PROFESSOR: So the thing is that
a process doesn't implicitly
use the capabilities.
So that's the cool thing
about capabilities.
You have to explicitly name
which one you're using.
So think of it in terms
of file descriptors.
Suppose that I give you an open
file descriptor for some file,
and it's read only.
And then someone else gives
you another capability
for some other-- maybe the same
filem maybe a different file,
and it's read/write.
It's not all of a
sudden that if you're
trying to write to the
first file descriptor
you had that was read
only, all of a sudden
those will start
succeeding because you
have this extra writeable
file descriptor open.
So that's sort of
the cool thing.
You don't want this
ambient privilege.
Because if you think
of these capabilities
as a bunch of privileges
that just keep accumulating
in your process, then
you'll actually just
end up with ambient
privilege again.
You just have all these
magic capabilities,
and people have actually
built such libraries.
Basically, well, they manage
your capabilities for you.
They sort of collect them.
And when you try to
perform an operation,
they look for the
capabilities and find
the one that'll make it work.
That exactly brings you back
to this ambient authority
that you were trying to avoid.
So the cool thing
about capabilities
is that it's almost like
a programming construct,
where it makes it
easy for you-- which
is a rare thing in
security-- it makes it easier
for you to write
code that specifies
exactly what privileges you
want to do from a security
standpoint.
And it's actually a fairly
natural code to write.
So if you get into that mindset
of always carrying around
this privilege with the
object you're accessing,
it seems like a
cool thing to do.
It doesn't always make
sense, but sometimes it does.
Any other questions?
OK.
So that's more on
the ambient authority
that we've look at here.
It turns out that
capabilities are also
great for other
problems, as well.
And in particular, the
problem of managing privileges
often shows up when you want
to run some untrustworthy code.
Because you want
to really control
which privileges you
give it, because you
think it will misuse any
privileges you give it at all.
And this is the slightly
different point of view
from which the authors
of the Capsicum paper
are coming at capabilities.
So they're of course clearly
aware of this ambient authority
problem, but it's sort
of a different problem
that you might or might
not care about solving.
But the particular thing
they really care about
is they have a really large
privileged application,
and they worry
that there's going
to be bugs in different parts
of that application source code.
So they would like to
reduce the privileges
of different components
of that application.
So in that sense, the story
is very similar to OKWS.
So you have-- for
sandboxing, you
have some large application,
you break it up into components,
and you will limit what
privileges each component has.
So where does this make sense?
Like OKWS is
clearly one example.
What are other situations
where you might
care about prileged separation?
Well, I guess in the paper
they describe the examples I
actually got to run.
So things like tcpdump
and other applications
that parse network data.
So why do they worry so
much about applications
that parse network inputs?
What goes wrong in tcpdump?
Why are they so paranoid?
AUDIENCE: Well, an attacker
can control what's being sent
and what's being called.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think what they
really worry about is,
very much like with OKWS, they
worry about that attack surface
and how much can an attacker
really control the inputs?
And with these network
parsing programs,
there's a lot of control
that that factor has.
They have the exact packet.
And the reason that
this was so problematic
is that if you're
writing code in C that
has to parse data
structures, you're presumably
going to do lots of
pointer manipulations,
copying bites into
arrays, allocating memory.
And as you are now experts,
this is super fragile.
And you can easily have
memory management errors
that lead to pretty
disastrous consequences.
So this is the
reason why they're
very excited about sandboxing
various network protocol,
parsing things, et cetera.
Another probably
real world instance
where you really care about
this is in your browser.
You probably want to
sandbox your Flash plug-in,
or your Java
extension, or whatnot.
Because they're
pretty large attack
surfaces as well
that have gotten
exploited pretty aggressively.
So it seems like
a reasonable plan.
Like if you're writing
some piece of software,
you want to sandbox
different components of it.
What about more generally,
if you download something
from the internet,
and you want to run it
with fewer privileges?
Is this sort of Capsicum style
isolation a good plan for that?
I could download some random
screensaver or some game
from the internet.
And I want to run
it on my computer,
and I want to make sure
it doesn't screw up
whatever I have laying around.
Would you use Capsicum?
Would this be a good plan?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could write
a sandboxing program,
which you'd use Capsicum
to sandbox [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
You could try to use Capsicum.
So how would you use Capsicum?
Well, you'd just enter into the
sandbox mode with cap_enter.
And then you run the program.
Would you expect it to work?
I guess the problem is that
if the program wasn't really
expecting to be
sandboxed with Capsicum,
then all of a sudden the
program will try to open any
simplified-- it'll
open a shared library,
and it can't open
the shared library,
because it can't
open/liv/ something else.
That's not allowed
in capability mode.
So it's a bit of a problem.
So typically, these
sandboxing techniques
that we're going to look at
here-- capabilities, style,
stuff, and so on--
really are best
used when the developer
is sort of building
the application aware
that the code is
going to run in this mode.
There's probably other kinds
of sandboxing techniques
that could be used
for unmodified code,
but then the focus, or the
requirements, change a bit.
So in Capsicum,
they don't really
worry about backwards
compatibility.
Well, we have to open
files differently?
Sure, we'll open
them differently.
Whereas, if you want
to write existing code,
you probably want
something more like maybe
a full virtual machine.
So you could open a
VM and run it there.
And it's very
compatible, and there's
no question that it'll just
run, and probably not--
Well, it's actually a
good thought exercise.
Should we use virtual machines
to sandbox instead of Capsicum?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The overheads are probably
quite significant.
So the memory overhead
is pretty bad.
It could be.
But what if we don't care
about memory overhead?
So maybe virtual machines
gets really good,
and they don't actually
use that much memory.
Is it still a bad plan?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it's kind of hard to control
what happens on the network,
because either you give the
virtual machine no access
to the network at all, or
you connect to a network
through NAT mode or something
in Preview or VMware.
And then it can access
the whole internet.
So you have to much more
explicitly control network
by maybe setting up firewall
rules for the virtual machine,
et cetera.
That's maybe not so great.
What if you don't
care about network?
What if you're some simple
video or tcpdump parser.
You just spin up a VM.
It's going to parse
your tcpdump packets
and spit you back
after your presentation
that tcpdump wants
to burn to the user.
So there's no real
network I/O. Maybe you're,
for some reason
[INAUDIBLE] still?
AUDIENCE: Because the
initialization overhead
is still large.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it's maybe like an initial
overhead of starting a VM.
So that's true.
There's some performance stuff.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, you might
want to have database rights
and things like that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But even more generally,
what you're getting at
is what if there's a real
data that you care about here?
And it's really hard to share.
So VMs are really
a much more sort
of separation mechanism, where
you can't really share stuff
across VMs very easily.
So it's good for
situations where
you have a very isolated program
you want to run, you basically
don't want to share any
files with any directories,
any processes, any pipes even.
And you just let
it run separately.
So it's great.
It's probably, in some ways,
stronger isolation than what
Capsicum provides, because
there's probably fewer
ways for things to go wrong.
And, you know,
all these problems
we talked about so far.
But it's also not applicable
in many of the situations
where you might want
to use Capsicum,
because in Capsicum,
you can actually
share files that have very fine
granularity between sandbox
[INAUDIBLE] by just giving it
capability to [INAUDIBLE] file.
This is something that's
very easy to do in Capsicum,
and would require quite
a bit of machinery
in a virtual machine setting.
That makes sense?
Questions?
All right.
So does that seem like
a useful primitives
to have to maybe sandbox stuff.
So I guess we're going to
talk about different ways
to try to sandbox something.
And Capsicum in particular
is the new thing here
that uses capabilities.
But just by comparison,
I guess, you
can do some sandboxing in
Unix, as we saw with OKWS.
Right?
It's just not great from
several standpoints.
So let's maybe take
the example of tcpdump
and see why tcpdump is difficult
to sandbox with Unix mechanism.
So remember, in the Capsicum
paper, these guys took tcpdump.
And the way tcpdump
works is that it
opens some special sockets and
then runs basically parsing
logic on network packets.
And it proceeds and prints them
out to the users' terminal.
So what would it take to sandbox
tcpdump with Unix primitives?
Have you restricted privileges?
So I guess the one
problem with Unix
is that you basically have
to-- well, the only way
to really change
privileges is to change
the inputs into the
decision function that
decides whether you can actually
access some object or not.
And the only things
you can really change
are, well, you can change
the privilges of the process,
which means it sends
UID to something else.
Or you could change
the permissions
on various objects that are
laying around in your system.
Or probably both,
in fact, right?
If you wanted to
sandbox tcpdump,
you'd probably have to
pick some extra user ID
and switch to that
while you're running.
Probably not an ideal
plan, because you probably
don't mean for multiple
instances of tcpdump
to run as the same user ID.
So if I compromise one
instance of tcpdump,
it doesn't really mean I
want to allow that factor
to now control the other
instances of tcpdump running
on my machine.
So that's potentially a bad
part of using user IDs here.
Another problem is that,
in Unix, you actually
have to be root in
order to change the user
ID of the process or something
else, or user privileges
or switch them to
something else.
That's not great either.
And another problem
is that, regardless
of what your user ID
is, there could be files
that allow access to them.
So there could be world
writable or world readable files
in your file system.
Like your etc password file.
Regardless of what your
UID is, the process
will still be able to
read that password.
So that's not so nice.
So the result, in order
to sandbox a unit,
you probably have to do both--
some UID changing and maybe
careful look at the
permissions of all the objects
to convince yourself that
there's no world writeable
file that's really sensitive.
Or there's no
world readable file
that you don't want that
hacker to get access to.
And I guess [INAUDIBLE] true
that you get another mechanism
unit that you can use.
But it all starts to add up.
If you see it
through, then it might
be hard to share files or
share directories and so on.
So does that make sense?
Just in terms of
contrast for what
Capsicum is trying to solve?
Any questions about Unix stuff?
All right.
So let's look at how Capsicum
tries to solve this problem.
So in Capsicum, as
we keep alluding to,
the plan is very much that once
you enter the sandboxing mode,
everything is going
to be accessed only
through capability.
So if you don't
have a capability,
you simply cannot
access any objects.
So these guys, in the
paper, make a huge deal
about global namespaces.
So what's this thing
about a global namespace,
and why are they so
worried about it?
What's an example of
a global namespace
these guys worry about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So a file system from them
is sort of the prime example
of a global namespace.
You can start a slash, and
you can basically enumerate
any file you could, right?
Like go to someone's
home directory--
/home/nickolai/
something, something.
Why is this bad?
Why are they against global
namespaces in Capsicum?
What do you think?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, if you
have the wrong permissions,
then use authorities, and
then you can get in trouble.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the problem is that
this is Unix after all.
So there are still regular
permissions on file.
So maybe you really want
to sandbox some process
and can't read anything
at all in the system
and can't write to anything.
But if you can name a file
starting from scratch,
you'll find some stupid user
that has a world writable
file in their home directory.
And that would be not so great
for the sandboxing client.
And I guess more generally,
the way they're thinking of it
is that, with capabilities, you
could, in principle, enumerate
exactly all the objects
that a process has.
Because you could just
enumerate all the capabilities
in the file descriptor table,
or whatever it is that's
storing capabilities for you.
And those are the only things
that the process could ever
touch.
And if you ever have access
to our global namespace,
and this was
potentially unbounded.
Because you could--
even if you have
some limited set
of capabilities,
maybe you'll start from slash
again and find some new file,
and you'll never
really know what
is the set of
operations or objects
that a process could access.
So this is the reason they're so
worried about global namespaces
because it goes against their
goal of precisely controlling
all the things that a sandbox
process should have access to.
Make sense?
All right.
So they tried to eliminate
global namespaces
with a bunch of kernel changes
to the FreeBSD, in their case,
kernel to make sure that
all the operations go
through some kind of capability,
which is, in their case,
a file descriptor.
So just to double check, do
we really need kernel changes?
What if we just do
this in a library?
So we implement Capsicum, which
they already have a library.
And all we do is we change
all these functions,
like open, read, and write,
to all very exclusive use
capabilities.
So all operations will go
through some capability,
and look it up in the
file table, et cetera.
Does that work?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could
always make a sys call.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the problem is that there
was this existing set of systems
calls the kernel will accept.
And even if you
implement a nice library,
it doesn't prevent a bad
process or a compromised process
from making the
sys call directly.
And then you have to
have the kernel enforce
something or other.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I think it's a
question of-- I guess
what is your threat model?
Exactly.
So for the compiler,
the threat model
is that the programmer is
maybe not paying attention
a whole lot, but it's not really
a compromised compiler process,
not an arbitrary code.
So if we just help the
well-meaning developer do
the right thing, then a
library will probably suffice.
On the other hand, if we're
talking about a process that
could be our executing
arbitrary code
and could be trying to
bypass our mechanisms
in any possible
way, then we have
to have a strong
enforcement boundary.
And a library doesn't provide
any kind of strong enforcement
guarantees.
Whereas a kernel, in
our case, would do that.
OK.
So what do they actually make in
terms of changes to the kernel?
So I guess the first
thing is this system call
that they call cap_enter.
And what happens once
you run cap_enter?
Once you've [INAUDIBLE]
cap_enter from your process?
So as far as I can
tell, what happens
is that the kernel will stop
accepting any system calls that
refer to global namespaces.
And the only thing
you'll be able to do
is refer to existing
file descriptors
that you have open
in your process.
So cap_enter will put your
process in a special mode where
you cannot use the regular
system called open,
and instead you have to
do things like openat.
So there's this
new sort of family
of systems called, in Unix
like operating systems, where
instead of having open
take a single path name,
you can actually
you openat, where
you pass it a first
argument which
is a file descriptor
for a directory
and the second is
some sort of a name.
And the open at system
call will open this name
relative to whatever directory
the file descriptor points to.
So this is a much more
capability-like version
of open, where you can still
have file descriptors pointing
to directories, but
you can-- well, sorry.
You can still direct
your operation.
But in order to
do this, you have
to have a capability
to the directory
in the form of an open
file descriptor for that
[INAUDIBLE].
Make sense?
OK.
So do they need any
other kernel changes?
Is there anything
else they worry about?
So I guess there's
another-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So what do they do about
network access, right?
So what happens in
capability mode?
AUDIENCE: I guess they have
capabilities for security
packets [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So I think the
way they basically
do it is that they treat the
network as a global namespace,
very much like a file system.
So I think once you
enter capability mode,
you cannot create a new socket.
Or you cannot create a new
socket and connect to some
arbitrary machine, or to some
arbitrary address or fort
number.
You have to basically create all
the connections you want ahead
of time and fill them
in as capabilities.
Or maybe you'd have to get
them from someone that will
pass you a file descriptor.
But basically, once
you're in capability mode,
the set of file descriptors you
have open completely enumerates
all the machines
you'll ever talk to.
So you can find
open connections.
Maybe you're
listening on a forge.
That's OK.
But you cannot connect
to an address specified
by an absolute name, kind of
like a global namespace would
allow you to do it.
That make sense?
So it's access through the
networking namespace, as well.
What do they do for processes?
So another global
namespace, I guess, in Unix,
is the the PIDs themselves.
So the example of a
system call that operates
in this name space is "kill."
So I could kill PID 25.
And I could-- well, presumably
I'll put a single number
in there, too.
But I could actually kill a
process by its PID number.
How do they fix
this in Capsicum?
What's their plan?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: File descriptors
with processes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's actually kind of cool.
It's like, I wish Unix
had this all along.
Which is that, instead of
having these different kinds
of numbers or PIDs, instead,
when you fork off a process,
actually having
new variant of fork
called pdfork, or
Process Descriptor Fork.
And what it does is when
it creates a child process,
it actually sticks a reference
to that child process
into your file descriptor
table somewhere.
And this is your new process.
And you can operate
on a child process
by specifying the file
descriptor number.
Well, it would be pretty
cool, because you can now
pass your child
process to someone else
and say, well, if you
can go and kill them now,
or you can manage this
process however you want,
you'll get notifications
when the process dies.
It'll look like a readable
file descriptor, et cetera.
So they really try to
homogenize everything
into looking like a file
descriptor of some sort here.
And with these
kernel changes, you
can finally have all
the functionalities
you might care about.
You have the support
for sockets already,
process descriptors, et cetera.
And you have a way
of constraining
what the process can do.
Because it cannot refer to any
of the global names anymore
after [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
Any questions?
So here's an interesting puzzle.
I was trying to
understand from the paper.
They make a big
deal about dot dot
in looking up directory names.
So they basically say, well,
once you're in capability mode,
when you pass a
particular name to openat,
you cannot use dot
dot in those names.
And presumably, if
you have a Simulink,
if a Simulink's target
contains dot dot,
they will reject it if
you're in capability mode.
So is this strictly required?
Could you imagine a
safe design in principle
that allows the use of dot dot?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, you'd need to be
able to find whether they have
a file or a capability that
allows the masses to the parent
directory.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So it's
trivial to go down,
because any subdirectory--
you already have access to it
by having the capability.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But going
up, you need to see
whether you have any
capabilities for the parent
directory.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Search for it somehow.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's a little bit tricky.
And also, it goes
against the grain
of this whole explicit
authority thing.
What about if you're
using dot dot inside sort
of a single open call?
So for example, what if you
call something like openat some
particular directory or
file descriptor number,
and you open something like,
I don't know, b/c/../..?
In principle, this
might be safe, right?
Because you go down some
directory, and then you just
climb back up out of it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What if
c is [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it's a little bit
tricky, of course,
to define exactly what
it means to be safe.
Right?
You probably have to make sure
that c isn't a Simulink that
goes somewhere else and so on.
Yeah.
That's a fairly tricky
proposition, to get this right.
And I think, in the
paper, what they basically
argue about is
that it's actually
quite difficult in practice
to implement a set of checks
that's sufficient and
bypasses all the possible rate
conditions here.
So they basically just
do the conservative thing
and disallow any
dot dot at any time
once you're in capability mode.
There's some interesting
rate conditions
you could come up with here.
The lecture notes
have more details.
But basically I
think these guys are
being extra cautious in
defining what's allowed
and what's not allowed
in capability mode.
OK.
So here, to answer
your question,
once you enter
capability mode, it
seems to be all controlled
by your file table.
Does your UID still matter,
once you enter capability mode?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, you could
still launch a process
that doesn't use capabilities.
PROFESSOR: No.
Actually, no, you can't.
You have to make sure that--
otherwise you could escape,
like well, I can't access--
why don't you run this guy?
[INAUDIBLE]
So yeah, cap_enter is inherited
by all the children, which
is actually hugely important.
Yeah?
Anyone else?
So what if we kill the UID?
So it's supposed to be
like going to cap_enter,
and we just kill the UID
of the current process.
We don't actually care
what it is anymore.
And then the process
tries to open a file.
What checks should apply?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I was
thinking that the UID is
useful for logging
purposes as well,
like being able to tell
if you did something.
PROFESSOR: So
yeah, you're right.
Actually, yeah.
So that would be actually
kind of damaging, right?
Like I spawned some sandbox
process on my machine
and it loses the UID.
I'm like I have a
hundred processes running
on my machine, and I have
no idea what they are.
So that's probably not a good
plan for a management purpose.
You're absolutely right.
But I'm just sort of
hypothetically saying, well,
do we need it for
access control, I guess.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe if
this UID is only
supposed to be able to
access this file by reading
or whatever, but you have
the file descriptor for it,
but then if you
lose the UID, you
might get permissions to write
[INAUDIBLE] or something?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think actually what it
shows up in is in directories.
Because once you add a
capability to a file,
that's basically it.
You have it open with particular
privileges, et cetera.
But the problem is that they
have this hybrid design where
they say, well, you can
actually add capabilities
to directories, and
you can open a new file
as you're running along.
And it might be the case
that you add a capability
to a directory, like /etc.
And you don't have access
to necessarily all the files
in /etc.
But once you enter
capability mode,
you can now try to open
those files by saying, well,
I have access to
the /etc directory.
It's open already.
Why don't you give
me the file named
password in that directory?
And the kernel still needs to
make an access control decision
on whether to allow you to
open a file in that directory
with either read mode or
write mode or what have you.
So I think this is the one
place where you still need
this ambient privilege, to
some extent, because they're
trying to build this
compatible design where
you can have semi-natural
semantics for how directories
work.
Does that make sense?
it's like one leftover place,
kind of for compatibility
reasons, or at least the
way that Unix file systems
are typically set up.
AUDIENCE: Are there
any other places?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
I couldn't think
of one off hand,
but I guess I would have to
get their previous desource
code to really figure
out what's going on.
I think most of the
other situations
don't really
require a UID check.
Because for networking,
it doesn't show up.
I think for process descriptors
it doesn't show up, either.
If you have it, then
you just have it.
So I think it probably is
just file system operations.
For shared memory, it's also--
once you have a shared memory
segment, you have it open.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could
you explain again
how exactly the user ID matters
if you have a capability?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I think where it
matters is, you have
a capability to a directory.
The question is, what does
the capability represent?
So one interpretation that--
for example, some capability
system state, not Capsicum.
Pure capability systems.
They say, well, if you have
a capability to a directory,
then of course you have
access to all the files
in that directory, no
questions about it.
And in Unix, this is
typically not the case.
You can open a
directory like /etc,
but there's lots of system
files in there that are maybe
private, like the private key of
your server is stored in there.
And just because you can look
at a directory and open it
and list it doesn't mean that
you cannot open the files
in that directory.
So in Capsicum, if you
open a directory like /etc,
and then you enter
capability mode.
And then you say,
well, hey, I don't
know what this directory is.
I just add a file
descriptor to it.
There's a file in
there called "key."
Why don't you open
that file "key"?
And at this point,
you probably don't
want to allow this
capability-based processor
to just open it, because
that wasn't the intent.
They'll allow you to bypass
the Unix permissions on a file.
So I think the
authors of this paper
are careful to design a
system which would not violate
existing security mechanisms.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
that you can, in some cases,
use a combination of the two?
So even though it'll be able
to change it to directory,
inside the directory,
which files you can access
depends on your user ID?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So in Capsicum, the way they
get it to work in practice
is that, actually, before
you enter capability mode,
you have to guess.
Well, what files am I
going to need later?
I'm going to need
some shared libraries.
I'll need some text files.
I'll need some templates.
I'll need some network
connections, et cetera.
So you open all these
things ahead of time.
And you don't always necessarily
know which exact file you need.
So what these guys
support as well,
you can actually just open
a directory file descriptor,
as well.
And then I can look up the
particular files later.
But it might be
that the files don't
have all the same permissions.
So that's exactly
the reason, yeah.
Make sense?
All right.
So this is the kernel
mechanism part of it.
Why do they also need this
library for libcapsicum?
I guess there's two things that
they support in that library,
as far as I can tell,
or two main things.
One is that they implement this
function they call lch_start
that you should use
instead of cap_enter.
And the other sort of
feature the library provides
in libcapsicum is this
notion called fd lists
instead of passing file
descriptors by number.
So this fd list
thing is probably
the easiest thing to explain.
It's basically a generalization,
or maybe a clean up,
of how Unix manages
and passes file
descriptors between process.
So in traditional
Unix and Linux,
how you use it today, typically
when you launch a process,
you can pass it some
file descriptors.
You just open some
file descriptors
at particular integer
numbers in this table
and you run the child
process that you want to run.
Or you run a particular
binary, and it
inherits all these open
slots in the fd table.
But there's no real good
way to name these things
other than by number.
So the somewhat
surprising convention,
if you haven't
[INAUDIBLE] before,
is that, well, slot
0 is your input.
Slot 1 is your output.
Slot 2 is where you should
print error messages to.
And that's how
Unix sort of works.
And it sort of works OK if you
are just passing these three
files or streams to a process.
But in Capsicum,
what's happening
is that you're passing down many
more file descriptors around.
So you're passing a file
descriptor for some files.
You're passing a file descriptor
for a network connection,
for a shared library,
what have you.
And it becomes much more tedious
to manage all these numbers.
So basically, libcapsicum
provides an abstraction
for naming these past file
descriptors between processes
by some sort of a
hierarchical name,
instead of just these opaque
integers, if you will.
So that's one sort
of simple thing
that they provide
in their library.
So I can pass a file
descriptor to a process
and give it a name.
And it doesn't really
matter what number it has,
a little easier.
That make sense?
OK.
So then they have
this other mechanism,
this much more elaborate
way to start a sandbox.
This lch, libcapsicum Host,
API for starting a sandbox,
instead of just entering
the capability mode.
So what happened?
Why do they need something
more than just entering
capability mode?
What are you worried about
on creating a sandbox?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It erases
all the inherited stuff
to give you a clean start.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I think they
worry about trying
to enumerate what are all the
things the sandbox has access
to.
And the problem is that if
you just call cap_enter,
technically, at the kernel
mechanism level, as we talked
about just now, it worked.
Right?
It just prevents you from
opening any new capabilities.
But the problem is that there
might be lots of existing stuff
that the process
already has access to.
So I guess the simplest
example is maybe
there are some file descriptors
that you forgot you had opened,
and it'll just get
inherited by this process.
So one example is they
were looking at tcpdump.
And they realized that-- well,
first, they changed tcpdump
just by calling
cap_enter at the point
just before they were about to
parse all the network input.
So this works well, in some
sense, because you can't
get any more capabilities.
But then they looked at
the open file descriptor,
and they realized that you have
complete access to the user's
terminal, because you have an
open file descriptor to it.
So you can actually
sniff all the keystrokes
that the user is typing
and all that stuff.
So it's probably not a
great plan for tcpdump.
This compromise you probably
don't want sniffing everything
you're typing.
So instead they-- well,
in tcpdump's case,
they manually changed
these file descriptors
to add some capability
bits to them,
to restrict what kinds
of operations you can do.
So remember, the capability,
at least in Capsicum,
has these extra bits that say,
here's the class of operations
you can perform on
a file descriptor.
So they basically take what
used to be file descriptor 0.
It pointed to the
user's terminal, tty.
And originally, this was
just a direct pointer
to the tty structure
in the kernel.
What they do is they
actually-- in order
to limit the kind of operations
you can perform on this file
descriptor, they basically
introduced some extra beta
structure in the middle.
This guy will point
to the terminal.
And the file
descriptor itself will
point to some sort of
a capability structure.
And inside of it is the
pointer to the real file
that you're trying to access,
as well as some restricted bits
or permissions on
that file descriptor
object that you can do.
In their case, they basically
can say for tcpdumps standard
input, you cannot
do anything on it.
You can just see that it
exists, and that's it.
For the output file
descriptor, they say,
well, you can write to it, but
you maybe can't reposition.
You can't [INAUDIBLE]
back and forth, et cetera.
Make sense?
So what else would
you worry about,
in terms of starting a sandbox?
So there is, I guess, the
file descriptor state.
Anything else that matters?
Well, I guess in Unix it's
file descriptors and memory.
That's pretty much it.
So the other thing that
these guys worry about
is that it might be that
in your address space,
you previously allocated
some sensitive data.
And the process
that your sandbox
is going to be able to
read all its memory.
So if there's
maybe some password
that you checked before when
the user was logging in,
and you haven't
cleared that yet,
well, the sandbox
process will be
able to read that
and do something
maybe interesting to that.
So the way they
solved this problem
is, in lch_start, you basically
have to start a program fresh.
You basically take a program.
You explicitly package
up all the arguments
you want to give it.
You explicitly package up
all the file descriptors
you want to give it.
And then you start
a new process,
or you would call
executives to reinitialize
your whole virtual memory space.
And then there's no
question about what
is the set of sensitive
data of extra privileges
that this process has.
It's exactly what you
passed to lch_start,
in terms of a program name,
arguments, and capabilities.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: What would happen
if the process that you're
starting is a setuid 0 binary?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think these guys say
that they don't actually
allow setuid binaries
in capability mode,
just to avoid some
weird interactions that
would show up.
I think the rules
that they implement
is that you could have
a setuid program that
gets its privileges
from a setuid binary,
and then it can call
capenter or lch_start.
But once you're in
capability mode,
you cannot regain
extra privileges.
In principle, this could work,
but it would be very weird.
Because remember, the only
place where the UID matters,
once you're in
capability mode, is
in opening these files
inside of a directory.
So it's not clear this
is really a great plan
for getting more privileges
or [INAUDIBLE] there.
Make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We talked
about earlier
why the library doesn't really
support strict separation
between those two.
And then we just mentioned
all these problems
that you could use
[INAUDIBLE], so we're still
not under a restriction to use
lch_start necessarily, right?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
So lch_start, here's sort
of the way to think of it.
So you have an application,
like maybe tcpdump.
Or gzip is the other
thing they work with.
And what you're
basically assuming
is the application is
probably not compromised,
and there are some core part
of the application that you
worry about sandboxing.
In tcpdump's case, it's
actually parsing packets
coming from the network.
In gzip's case, it's
actually taking the file
and decompressing it.
And you're basically assuming,
well, up until a point,
the process is probably
doing all the right things.
It's not exploited.
There's probably not a bug
yet for the [INAUDIBLE] even.
So at that point,
you're trusting
that it will run lch_start
correctly and correctly set up
the image, correctly set
up all the capabilities,
and then restrict itself from
making any further system calls
outside its capability mode.
And then you run
the dangerous stuff.
And by then, this setup
has happened correctly,
and there's no way to
escape out of that sandbox.
Make sense?
All right.
So I guess let's look at how
you actually use capability mode
to sandbox applications.
So we talked a little
bit about tcpdump.
How do you isolate this process?
Another interesting
example they had
was this gzip program that
compresses, decompresses files.
So why do they worry
about sandboxing it?
I guess they worry that the
decompression code is going
to be potentially
buggy, or maybe there's
some memory management
errors in how
they manage the buffers during
decompression, et cetera.
So could they-- well, one
interesting question, I guess,
is why are the changes to
gzip seemingly much more
complicated than for tcpdump?
Any guesses?
Well as far as
you can tell, it's
mostly just a question of how
the application is structured
internally, right?
So if you had a application
that simply compressed
a single file, or
decompressed a single file,
then it might be OK for us to
just run it in capability mode
without really changing it.
You just give it a new standard
in for something to decompress,
and the standard out goes
to the decompressed output,
and that would work fine.
The problem, as is
almost always the case
here with these kind of
sandboxing techniques,
is that the application actually
has much more complicated logic
around it.
So gzip, for
example, can compress
multiple files, et cetera.
And in that case, you have some
sort of a driver process on top
which actually has
these extra privileges
to open multiple files, to
create things, et cetera.
And the core logic needs to be
often another helper process.
And it was just so
the case in gzip
that the application
wasn't structured
in a way where this was already
a separate process doing
all the decompression
or compression.
So they had to change
gzip's core implementation,
and, well, some structure of
the gzip application, instead
of just passing the data
to the decompression
function to actually
send it over an RPC call
or really just write it to
some almost file descriptor
to help process the
problems on the side
and performs all
the decompression
with almost no privileges.
The only thing it
can do is return
the decompressed data,
or the compressed data,
back to the caller process.
That roughly make sense?
What's going on in gzip?
All right.
So I guess one thing we asked
for the homework is how do you
actually use Capsicum in OKWS?
So what do you guys think?
Would it be useful?
Would the OKWS guys
have been excited
and switched to FreeBSD because
this was much easier to use?
Or is this a wash?
So what do you think?
How would you use
Capsicum in FreeBSD?
Would this be much different?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it means
you can get rid of some
of the jailing [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's true.
So truth seems to be completely
superseded by this plan
of having directory file
descriptors and capabilities.
So that's great.
So you don't need the
chroots setting it up.
That seems messy.
And this is much
more precise, also.
Because you can--
instead of having
a chroot with lots of
little things in there,
you have to maybe set the
permissions on there carefully.
You can just open exactly
the files that you need.
So that seems like a plus.
Any other benefits?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: In OKWS, you mean?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So in OKWS, right, you have
this OK launcher daemon that
had to launch all these guys.
And it was the parent process.
Only when they die,
the signal goes back
to this okld to restart
the crash process.
And that thing had to
run this root, because it
had to sandbox things.
There's actually a number of
things you could do better
with Capsicum in OKWS.
So one example is
you could probably
have okld have many
fewer privileges.
Because it might need to be
root initially to get fort 80.
But after that, it could set
up sandboxes for everyone else
without being root anymore.
So that's kind of cool.
And maybe you can
even delegate the job
of responding a process
to someone else,
maybe a per service
monitor Damion
that just has this
process descriptor handle,
or process descriptor
for child process,
and whenever it crashes,
starts a new one.
So I think this process
[INAUDIBLE] helps things a lot.
And the fact that you can create
a sandbox without being root
is also quite helpful, as well.
Any other stuff,
what you could do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You
could give each one
a file descriptor with
append only mode to the log.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's pretty cool.
So as we were talking
last time, in OKWS,
well, the oklogd maybe could
hamper with the log file.
And who knows what
the kernel will
allow it to do once it has
a file descriptor on the log
file itself.
But here, the fact
that we can do
much more of a
precise capability map
on a file descriptor, well,
we could give it a log file
and say, well, you could just
write to it, but not seek.
So that basically
means append only,
if you're the only
writer to that file.
So that seems kind of nice.
And you could prevent
it from reading a file.
You could say, well, you can
only write, but not read,
which is something
that's probably
difficult to do with Unix
permissions alone right now.
Make sense?
Any other ideas for how
Capsicum might help?
Would you wish there was
more stuff in Capsicum?
I guess we always wish
there was more stuff.
AUDIENCE: So one
thing that perhaps
may be tricky is the
service team daemons need
to connected to their
backend databases somehow.
Which might be remotely.
But you don't want
the launch daemon
to know about which
services each service
is going to connect to.
PROFESSOR: Maybe, yeah.
That's a good question, right?
So in Capsicum, as we
were talking about,
the network is in
global namespace.
You have to have
existing file descriptors
for all the outstanding
connections ahead of time.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But you don't necessarily want
okld to open up all the sockets
for all the services.
Because it might not know where
the services are connected.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
So that's a little bit
of an awkward thing.
I absolutely agree.
And this is part
of the reason why
I think capabilities
haven't completely
subsumed everything
in the security world,
is because they are
kind of awkward to use.
Because the guy that gives
you all the privileges
has to know exactly what
things you're going to need,
like these connections
to backend servers.
So at some level, maybe this
is not such a huge problem
in OKWS.
Because the launcher
daemon has to read a Config
file and is going to pass
the token to the service
in the first place.
So maybe the token is going
to contain the host and port
number to which
you're connected to.
But I agree.
It's not great.
Because especially,
suppose the database server
disconnects you.
Well, you're kind of stuck now.
The file server is
not connected anymore,
and you can't
connect to a new one.
So basically, if the database
server crashes, or restarts,
or the network
breaks, you basically
have to terminate it,
get yourself response,
so you can get a new one of
these connections past you.
So it's maybe not a
great plan in that sense.
AUDIENCE: Could we wrap the
system call, the function
[INAUDIBLE] to open a
socket so that it faults
the middleman instead of the
socket that the users send out
to [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is what I think the
FreeBSD guys have done since.
Well, there's a
bunch of situations
like this, where you want to
open some file after the fact,
or you want to connect
to something after going
into capability mode.
So the FreeBSD
developers have added
this daemon called Casper, that
every capability based process
has a handle on.
And this Casper daemon runs
outside of capability mode,
and basically
listens to requests
from sandbox processes.
And if you want
to open some file,
or if you want to send a
network connection, or a packet,
or something, but you didn't
have the right capability
beforehand, then this Casper
daemon will do it for you.
But it carefully
maintains a list of things
that every sandbox process
should or should not
be able to do.
So it's like a systems service.
So when you start a
capability process,
or enter capability
mode, by default,
this Casper thing will not allow
you to do anything extra funny.
But you could say,
well, hey, I'm
going to start the
sandbox process.
And you can ask Casper,
well, please allow my process
to do the following
things later.
So you could, right?
And the cool thing is that
you can pass file descriptors
or capabilities through
fd passing in Unix.
So once you have a handle
on this Casper guy,
you can get more
capabilities later on.
So it's, again, trade off
between being pure capability
world versus actually being
programmable or easy to use.
So it seems to be working out.
I think the particular thing
they use it for in FreeBSD,
or the thing that shows up
often, is making DNS queries.
So you want to be able to
make DNS queries once you're
in a sandbox.
And actually, this is a problem
they ran into with tcpdump.
Because when tcpdump is
printing your packets,
it wants to print the host
name for an IP address.
In order to do this, it has
to talk to a DNS server.
But you probably
don't want to connect
to a DNS server ahead of
time, or to every DNS server
you might ever need.
So instead, they use
this helper daemon
that's going to make
DNS queries for you.
Make sense?
All right.
So I guess the last thing
I wanted to talk about
is what are the security
guarantees that Capsicum
provides?
So should you trust it?
How could Capsicum go wrong?
Presumably you can always
have security problems,
regardless of what mechanism
you're using underneath.
But what particular
things should we
worry about in
Capsicum when we're
building some system here?
Suppose you have to
attack this thing.
You have to attack this
tcpdump thing, or gzip,
or whatever it is
that they implemented.
What would you look at, in
terms of bugs or problems?
AUDIENCE: Well, it
depends on the developers
knowing what they're doing.
So they might give
a bad capability.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
So it's actually one
interesting property of Capsicum
is that it's not a guarantee
that the user of the system
gets.
It's really a tool
that the developer
has to build more trustworthy
or better application software.
But I, as a user of the
system, have no idea
whether this is a
good or bad thing
that the application
is using Capsicum.
You could totally misuse it,
as you're absolutely right.
So maybe one example is,
as they show in the paper,
you could give too many
privileges to the sandbox
process.
Like the the TCP
helper, or maybe
it has access to my console.
And that's not so great,
but it's hard for me
as a user to really tell this
in a general purpose fashion.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It might also be that
when you set the permissions
to the masks on any
given file descriptor
that you set two
permission masks.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right.
So it's not just the
file descriptors.
Also, what can you do with
those file descriptors?
You're right.
Yes.
These maps are another
part of the story
that you have to watch out for.
OK.
So suppose we got
the masks right.
We got the file
descriptors right.
We haven't used lth_start.
There's nothing extra in memory.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's true.
Yes.
So maybe there's like
something before you even
add the capability
mode that's damaging.
So it only helps
once you jump in.
And one slightly
annoying thing is
that it seems like it can't do
a whole lot inside of capability
mode, not in the sense that you
can't run large computations,
but you can't really put a large
part of a complicated system
into capability mode.
Because inevitably,
in Unix, you'll
need to do something
with new processes,
opening network
connections, et cetera.
And you'll probably
need to use some
of these global
namespaces that are not
available in capability mode.
So it's probably
going to be quite
difficult to put large chunks
of logic or intricate system
code inside of capability mode.
So only well-defined
chunks of an application
are likely to be running
in capability mode.
It depends.
I don't know if this is
entirely true or not.
In Chrome, for example,
large processes
do run in capability
mode in their design.
It might be that
you basically have
to have non-capability mode
chunks of your application
because you wanted to
incorporate nicely with Unix,
or whatever is is you're
running alongside of it.
OK.
Any other thing you
should worry about?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, whether they
implemented capabilities
correctly.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Whether they've
covered all the system calls.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yes.
So that's actually a huge
problem, in some sense,
already.
If you think about
it, there's probably
hundreds of system calls
that the kernel provides you.
And they're not especially
precisely documented,
so you probably have to
look at their implementation
and see if, for every
system call, if there's
some way for the
applications to get
the system call to
perform some operation
on some extra object that didn't
have a file descriptor to it.
And most Unix
system calls weren't
written with the
expectation of everything
has to be operation
on a file descriptor.
So you really have to get
every system all right.
And probably more worryingly
is that the kernel has
to be free of bugs,
like buffer overflows
or whatever other memory
corruption like you guys
explained [INAUDIBLE].
Otherwise, all of this
is complete nonsense.
You just are on arbitrary
assembly code in the kernel,
and you have full
control of the machine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I guess, yeah.
So the one thing I didn't
get a chance to talk about
is alternative things.
So this is in FreeBSD.
Linux has this thing
called [INAUDIBLE],
that allows you to specify which
system calls you can operate.
If you squinted, it's
kind of like Capsicum
but very different, in
the sense that Capsicum
talks about specific
file descriptors
that you can operate.
And in Linux, the
[INAUDIBLE] mechanism
lets you talk about
specific system calls
that you could run.
So it's probably
less fine grained,
but it's what's
available in Linux today.
And it's actually
probably a good idea
to look at your applications
and see what system call do
you expect it to make
and then code in a filter
and allow it to make
only those system calls.
The problem is that if you have
any interesting applications,
it'll probably run exec
and open and write,
and that's probably enough
to do quite a bit of damage
to the system.
So that's why you probably want
the more fine-grained system
like Capsicum,
where you can say,
well, you can run right,
but only on this thing,
not on my entire home directory.
All right.
So I guess we're out of
time to talk about Capsicum.
So let's talk about
native clients
on Wednesday and a different
way to sandbox programs.